one of the things I've learned with
acting is like it's funny like during
this interview I I try to just be in the
moment and just don't think you know and
that's that's a reason that's the way I
go into auditions I you know I you know
I have my little method that I prepare
kind of have this moment I got to have
this beat and everything but um when I
go in there I just focus on the other
person and to be honest with you
everything that I was studying I don't
care about it's all about I think the
connection I think that's what's gonna
get you a job and everything like that
because when you're on set depending on
what you're doing you know you're doing
your have everything around you all
you're doing is reacting and you really
have to auditioning is is so much so
much harder than when you're actually on
set and so that's the only way that I
know how to succeed on audition it's
just focusing on on the Rieger
are you competitive with yourself or
with others I'm not really competitive
with that's a very interesting it's a
very well put question I'm not
competitive so much with other people
but I guess I'm competitive with the
self and the fact that I demand a lot of
myself and I this is you know I don't
want to sound conceited about everything
but I I feel like I'm supposed to be
doing this and I'm really really good at
this and it really upsets me sometimes
when I when I want to go into these
auditions and I have this game plan and
for some reason maybe I don't have that
connection it wasn't there it really
really like bums me out and almost to
the point where I'm getting better at
this where you know where it might ruin
my day but then we go back to the
advices you know I'm trying to give
myself and
you know one of the reasons why I have
my dog it's just it's okay life is okay
you know whether you're gonna be a
successful actor or not it's an a sense
not up to me I just have to go out there
and just do what I do and you know fate
will fate will decide what's the store
for him how do you handle others being
competitive with you um I really don't I
really don't think about it so one of
the things I don't put much thought into
it's just I um I just try to do the best
that I can do I mean I've booked jobs
where you brought us with you I felt
like I didn't give a good audition and
then I I don't book jobs where I I feel
like oh my god I just had a moment and
it's like freaking at least you the
audition with that great feeling and so
as far as others I mean I don't um I
really I really don't think about it
that much I mean I mean yeah I really
don't what do you attribute that to that
when you go into an audition and you
think wow I just really knock their
socks off and there's no response and
then there's other times when you don't
feel you've done
and then they choose you do you think
it's all based on a look at it-- mm-hmm
my book the number of commercials and
the bonus with you some of these
commercials um I'm just gonna say Karen
they're stupid and I go in there and I
just like do my thing and everything and
I just have fun and I think I go out I'm
like what did I just do
like that was done and then they'll call
me and so I think a lot of times the
commercials it may be about the look
which is uh which is cool I mean I you
know I have more of a character look and
I think that helps me but um but I don't
like that that's what I guess intrigues
me and like makes me compete competitive
with myself more about the TV and film
because it's so much not so much really
about the look it's really you have to
provide a substance to the character we
had talked to Bonnie Gillespie and she
said that sometimes the casting director
can sense when someone's trying too hard
yes you think when you go in with a
light-hearted thing and kind of just
okay this is it
I think maybe that they pick up on that
casting directors I mean I think they're
very good at knowing people I think
that's what makes them very very good I
I think yeah I think you're right I mean
they can take they can smell desperation
like before like but one minute before
you walk in the door and they just smell
it all over you and I mean that's goes
it all goes back I'm sorry I'm just
it all goes back to my dog you know I
just have to remember that everything is
okay just go in there have fun and
because if you really want something
sometimes like you know like you squeeze
it too hard then I'll sudden you look at
it it's it's not any good anymore
because you squeezed it too hard so I
don't know where I'm going with that but
um yeah it's like you have to just go in
there and just have fun and be in the
moment
you